cabin porn I found cabin porn people who
come here really love cabins this is
well I'm gonna I'm gonna go we'll get
some cabin porn so I just learned these
things called getaway cabin it's a
company that markets towards people that
live in the city that just need to
disconnect in the middle of the woods
I'm an introvert so I thought I would
love to do something like this but then
I thought it might make a more
interesting video to have somebody
that's an extrovert do this by
themselves so I'm gonna bring my
coworker Erik who's always talking he's
always on his phone he's always talking
about social media and his Instagram
followers I really want to get more
Instagram followers so why don't you
guys follow me I thought if anybody he
could benefit from something like this
I'm not gonna tell that he's by himself
because I don't think he would go
alright guys so I'm super excited about
this video I'm about to go on some sort
of like vacation I'll get to know
Christian he seems like a cool guy he's
talented he's very serious I don't think
he likes me very much so I'm surprised
he asked me to come here and elique aim
up to me asked me to come to the woods
with him I'm starting to think this I'm
sure it'll be fine
it'll be great I'm going to the woods
with Christian let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
so I told you that this was a ballet
class like disconnecting us
disconnecting and connecting with each
other so the first part of that is true
we're gonna be disconnecting I'm gonna
be nowhere near you during this video
like we are staying in cabins but we
have two separate cabins very far away
from each other in the middle of this
big piece of property so we're gonna
have no contact the entire time with
each other or anybody else what if I get
sick what if I get sick and I need to
call somebody now what I have a Jewish
mom what is it how am I gonna contact my
Jewish mom to tell her that I'm okay hey
mom I'm not going to be able to
communicate with you for the next 24
hours well she didn't seem to really
care I want everybody to know I'm not
happy about this situation I'm basically
being kidnapped
these next 24 hours you were gonna have
to first get over the fact that you
don't have a cell phone that you can be
on there's no social media what goes on
in your brain when you don't have any
distractions that's gonna be the cool
part of this video like nothing no we're
not that goes on in my brain but but
something's gonna go on your brain like
you're gonna get to a place where you're
going to be thinking the
the obvious I'm sure I'm sure right now
when you're bored the first thing you do
is you pick up your phone and you look
to see like has anybody emailed me as in
my texted me there any Instagram photos
I haven't seen yet you're gonna be out
in the woods and when you when you get
to that first level of boredom something
else is gonna happen you're gonna have
to make a decision to do something or
you're just gonna be sitting down and
looking your mind is gonna start
wandering your creative mind like what
can you create in those in those moments
when there's no noise you're really good
at selling what you're selling right now
but I still predict I'm going to hate
the next 24 hours Jesus
this looks terrifying on camera and in
real life okay please don't leave me can
we just can we change the frame of the
video and we just stay stay together no
please no please no my service is gone
I'm gonna be so lonely
get out know that you're leaving me yep
I just have to walk out of here
this is great [ __ ] alright I guess this
is a goodbye see you mom nope this is
gonna be a long 24 hours oh my god
well I'm in the woods alone I have no
idea where Christian is let's see what
happens okay so there's this little like
and something you don't even use keys
here it's a little code which I don't
trust because there's only six bet you
any killer who comes here could just
figure out what my coat is smells like
wood Jesus oh my god the bed is right by
a massive window I'm freaking out I know
I'm gonna wake up and I'm gonna open my
eyes and there's gonna be some creepy
dude standing right by the window Jesus
that's a lot of knives I need to get rid
of these knives they have this you know
where you see these kinds of things you
see these kinds of lights you see them
in horror movies that's the only time
you ever see these kind of like smoker
uses these lords what the hell is this
alien toilet
[Music]
what just happened and the food I got
some good foods I'm not gonna clean
about that they got some porridge they
had some good stuff look it's a cool
place but I'm scared I'm very very very
very very very scared I had nothing to
do right so just dropped off Eric and
his cabin and this is mine I love
everything about this I can get used to
this I have to imagine that Eric is
loving this it's so quiet here I'm like
really not used to it it's really eerie
literally listen
[Music]
so they gave me this little book now
what for people like me that will kind
of help you if it's your first time
being alone and you don't know what to
do and how to be without your cell phone
begin by writing out a commitment
something you would like to remember
when returning to civilization
take your time thinking about it the
deeper into your getaway you are the
clear you'll see what needs to be done
so it's time to get to writing it's kind
of nice to not have anything to worry
about I mean how often do you get to
just look into a fire and not have to do
or think about anything there is a part
of me that is starting to worry about
Eric though so you spent 30 minutes just
writing everything and not gonna tell
you what I wrote because that was more
for me I'm surprised I feel very relaxed
right now felt really good just writing
everything out I didn't think that one
one activity would just like change my
perspective on this experience so
quickly by I'm really ready to just
embrace this whole thing now the next
thing this book talks about forest
bathing and they recommend that you walk
around the forest and
I'm gonna go for a walk guys it got
darker guys I have no idea where I am I
was walking and then it started to get
dark what the [ __ ] was that
sorry I keep hearing still walk I
literally cannot see past like a foot in
front of me look I've been walking for
about two hours no idea where to go or
where I am
alright well I'm gonna go I'm just gonna
keep walking and hopefully I can find my
cabin I just woke up to wake up to this
is pretty cool alright so I'm gonna go
out just check on Eric alright here he
is don't see him okay I have no service
yes I drink I'm gonna get back to my
cabin see if maybe he just like what I'm
not looking for me if not there's a
trail it's not too far away I might take
a walk down just to see if he's there
I've noticed
I could hear him
oh I found it it was like there's like
20 feet away so I made it back to the
cap and just woke up and I actually feel
amazing and then I just woke up to
nature I'm just gonna go for a hike it's
so pretty I wish I you guys can't even
experience like what it smells like how
pretty I mean if you've been to a forest
then you know it's amazing I'm alone
right now with my thoughts there's no
one else here this feels so great just a
loud noise the loud sounds of water
this trip was the one
seven worth it I'm just here thinking I
feel so happy I feel incredible
[Applause]
and Christian
I'm not worried about anything I've got
no stretch I haven't checked
omeone soos entire time
I might have lost all my followers
without me there inserts rune shot
it's time to go
I really don't want to leave I've had an
incredible time this was awesome Thank
You Christian everyone should try being
in silence get bored be lonely good
things will come from that